la baie du monts-michel un paysage
exceptionnel pour cet éditeur des guides
ver Michelin ce territoire est trop
souvent délaissé par les touristes
préférant le monument classé patrimoine
mondial de l'humanité en voyageant et en
traversant cette baie on s'aperçoit que
le gens se concentrre un peu trop
facilement sur le mont la baie elle-même
dégage une une force et de ses paysages
avec cette grande étendue qui mérite je
pense vraiment qu'on la traite de
manière particulière au-delà des paysage
pour la réédition du guide Vert
Normandie Cotentin amori de valroger
veut souligner le charme pittoresque des
villages de l' baé et leur patrimoine
comme ici à jeuner je note par exemple
la présence mais qui est assez classique
dans la région de fameux Porsche en
avancé avec les petits bans de chaque
côté qui servaient à accueillir les gens
qui
discutaient sortie de l'église très
important l'hébergement nouvelle étape à
Saint-Jean le Thomas pour visiter cette
chambre d'ôte et rencontrer la proprie
ça a été un ancien relais postal
d'accord c'est un plus
puisqueê dans le guide ver Michelin bah
c'est une reconnaissance donc bah c'est
super après moins d'une semaine passée
sur le terrain amori de valroger rendra
son rapport ce mois de décembre l'enjeu
décerner pour la première fois une
troème étoile à la baie du montsmichel
en tant que Normand je serais peut-être
un peu chauvin je voudrais peut-être en
mettre trois tout de suite et et a donc
le rédacteur en chef il y a les auteurs
on est tous à participer les éditeurs
qui connaissent la région on essaie de
voir si au final cette distinction qui
est la plus haute de du guide Michelin
et peut être attribuée la décision sera
dévoilée au printemps prochain une
distinction importante pour attirer les
touristes 37000 exemplaires du précédent
Guide Vert Normandie cotanttin ont été
édités